So now that we understand the data structures, let's
put the data structures to work. Let's first look
at what happens on a page fault. On a
page fault, the node first coverts the virtual address to
a UID and once it converts it to the
UID it goes to the page ownership directory. And as
I mentioned, the page ownership directory is something that
I can trust. It'll tell me, given this UID I'll
tell you who the owner of this page is. And you go to him because he has the GCD
data structure for this. So, node A finds out the identity of the owner for this
UID, and that happens to be node B. So it sends the UID over to node B, and node
B, because it is the owner for this UID, it looks up its GCD data structure and
says, oh, the PFD that can translate
this UID which actually represents this virtual address
is actually contained in this particular node,
node C. So, that's the content of this
data structure, given a UID what is the node ID that contains the PFD. Remember
that PFD is equivalent of a page table
in the normal system and therefore that's the
node that I want to send this UID to so that we can do the translation
for this virtual address. So node B sends the UID over to node C, and node C
contains the PFD that has the mapping between the UID and the
page frame number that is backed by this node
for this UID, retrieves the page. It's a hit. Sends it over to
node A. Node A is happy. It can then map this virtual address into its internal
structure and the page fault service is complete
and it can resume the process that was blocked
for this page fault. So you can see
that, potentially, when a page fault happens I can
have three level of network communication. Of course
the first look up of the POD is local
to my node because this POD data structure is
replicated on every node. So from the UID, I can
find the owner for the UID. But then I
have to send a network message over to the node
that contains the GCD for this UID. And then
he'll then send it to the node that has this
page so that that page can come back. Now
this network communication I am willing to tolerate because it
is equivalent to performing the role of what the disk
would have done. And maybe it is much better than
going to a disk in order to get the missing
page. So, it is happening only on page fault and
since it is on a page fault, this network communication is okay. But, this is an
extra network communication. Fortunately, the common case is a page fault
is servicing the request of a local process on node A, and so the
page is a non-shared page and if it is a non-shared page most likely
the UID space that corresponds to the missing page is also managed
by this node. Or in other words, both the POD and the
GCD corresponding to a particular UID is mostly on this node
itself. And this is true for non-shared pages, and so A and
B are exactly the same node. So there is no network communication to go from the
POD to GCD to find out the PFD.
So hopefully the only network communication that happens
on every page fault is a network communication
to go to this node that is serving
the role of a disk and get the page from him. That's okay to incur because
it probably is much lesser than going to the disk in
order to do the page access. So the page fault service
for the common case is going to be pretty quick. So
the important message that I want you to get out of
this is that even though these distributed data structures may make
it look like you're going to have a lot of network
communication, the important thing to note is that it happens only
when there is a page fault. And since most of the page
faults, the common case, is going to be non-shared
pages. The data structure POD and GCD are probably
co-resident on the same node. So, even though I've
shown two different nodes here, A and B may
be exactly the same node. And so looking up
the PFD that currently is backing this particular UID
is going to be local to this node and
so we can directly go to the node that contains
the PFD and make the page fault service pretty quick.